[Music]
in this morning saturday
session the multi-instrumental maestro
of the 21st century
jacob collier the genre defined collier
who's already a four-time grammy winner
is nominated for another three
statuettes at next month's awards show
you will see collier's eye-popping
performances in a moment including a
christmas classic
but first he spoke with anthony mason
jacob collier has been called a musical
prodigy
a modern mozart at 26 he already has an
arm full of grammys
but an album of the year nomination did
that catch you a little by surprise
utterly by surprise yeah um a surprise
would be a huge vast understatement
[Music]
collier's sound jumps between genres
[Music]
the grammy-nominated jessie volume 3
is part of a four-album suite that
connects all the sounds that have
influenced him
in his basement music room is this
something you've been doing since you
were a little kid
oh yeah yeah so i actually i learned to
walk in this room
when i was one two three years old i've
always lived here i've always lived in
this house and this has always been the
music room of the house
collier grew up in london raised with
his two sisters
by his mom a professional musician is
that where some of this came from
i i think so i think so yeah she's
probably upstairs right now but yeah she
was
such a force for me as a boy and she's a
violinist and also a conductor
so my idea of what music was kind of
supposed to feel like was
arms and energy and spirit and and i
remember sitting on her lap as a
two-year-old and just listening to her
play above me
and that was a very special musical
memory
i was such a sponge growing up and i
think that i loved the idea that you
could drink in all of this stuff and
sort of let it come out
and i'd write a folk song and realize
that i'd accidentally put some dubstep
drop in it and
i think in my mind something about that
was quite cathartic when you started did
you have some sort of sense of what you
wanted to be
i wanted to be jacob i didn't have a
clue what that meant
but i knew that i wanted to do something
that felt
like it was a sort of summation of
things i loved
[Music]
as a teenager his youtube videos went
viral
and collier was signed by quincy jones
management team
how do you personally measure success
if that's the right word for you it's a
very good question
i think if i give myself goosebumps i've
achieved a
sense of success like i've done it i'm
feeling something
and you know we have a year like 2020
and it's actually hard to feel anything
sometimes
but he did it for npr's tiny desk
concert this summer
[Music]
all of those people in that video are
you yeah
yeah that was one of my my favorite
quarantine projects actually
collier says he hasn't been able to stop
creating
this year why do you think that is what
is it about this year
i think time has a different quality
this year i found this
this sense of creativity that i hadn't
felt since i was very young actually
it's almost like i could create without
there being a point to creating again
which i think is what made me first fall
in love with it